dans cette époque je suis moins mauvais
et les autres c'est tout ricardo bofill
architecte catalan un brin arrogant mais
assurément visionnaire antifranquiste
passer par le cinéma et la politique
il se définit comme un homme de gauche
qu'est ce qui nous dit à des gorges en
architecture aujourd'hui je crois qu'il
va dire défendre la ville défendre la
culture urbaine défendre le savoir vivre
en ville essayer de développer d aider à
développer la société du futur erapa
entre architecture et société c'est
aujourd'hui une attitude tandis que ceux
de gauche dans un esprit de post moderne
il a réalisé plusieurs constructions en
région parisienne les arcades du lac à
saint quentin en yvelines
les immeubles de l' axe majeur à
cergy-pontoise place de la catalogne à
paris et son oeuvre la plus emblématique
les espèces d'arbres access à
noisy-le-grand sépare le bâtiment
ordinaire cepal hlm première partout
surtout son idée réinventer le logement
social rompre avec les bars monotone et
créer de la vie qu'est ce que je vais
faire ici c'est une vie urbaine
c'est un monument c'est un monument
habitées c'est un hommage à la vie
quotidienne
je viens d'un pays latin je crois la
cité je crois la convivialité j'ai quoi
la vie en commun je crois aux valeurs de
la cité et j'ai des pharmacies des
rentes dont ces diverses réalisations
beau fils a pour projet de mêler les
populations dans des villes nouvelles
il ya beaucoup l'espace et on se
retrouve
un rendez vous hri tous les copains
c'est une architecture que j'aime une
liste rigide espaces et la conception
donc même de la résidence fait que la
vie entre propriétaires et la vie
associative a réussi à se développer de
façon intense et intéressant baroque
monumental inspirée de l'antiquité comme
de l' architecture africaine
l'oeuvre de beau fils inspire le cinéma
français et américains
il ya un côté opératique dans cette dans
cette architecture qui frappe qui est
très visuel et qui est en effet très
très belle et alors qu'il est naturel
puisqu'il n'a pas beaucoup vous savez la
grisaille et la monotonie et l'horreur
de grandes réalisations architecturales
surtout en europe depuis depuis 40 ans
donc on a envie plutôt de regarder ça qu
autre chose ça ne veut pas dire que je
voudrais vivre dedans
les espaces d'abraxas ce sont
aujourd'hui en partie vétustes et
touchées par l'insécurité la mairie de
noisy a fait appel à l'architecte pour
repenser le quartier et en faire un lieu
de vie à l'horizon 2021
[Musique]